speaking of like netflix anime and
everything like at
this weekend i haven't done this in a
while but i watched an entire show
in like one day oh get out of here
what is this 2013. it's it's it's it's
where is it
it's not a head dodo oh yeah yeah
so it's been a while like i started
watching it a while ago completely
forgot what happened so it's amazing
right
i his here's the thing
i've never lost a job so quick in my
life oh my god
i like i just like the way you said that
so casually it's like it's amazing right
and
and i just said so i mean okay here's
the thing
his thing i did like it but it's one of
these things where
that makes me hate being like an anime
fan right right
because it's one of those sh it's
impoverished i i i have this experience
so often right so you have you have this
13 episode series right
it's got so much potential it has a
really interesting world it has really
cool characters
and then just as you're starting to get
invested in everything nothing really
happens
really that was that was the manga bro
that that was dotto head dollar for me
right right because i i really love the
world it's one of the most interesting
worlds i've seen in a while
yeah like the like oh god like the whole
it's so [ __ ] brutal and the magic
system is really
weird as well it's it's it's a really
it's it's unconventional it's very
unconventional it's kind of like mad max
times psychopaths or something along
those lines does something have to
happen
like i mean because we're probably going
to get a season two probably i have
probably
that's that's no guarantee true
especially that's that's the thing right
that's the thing about being an anime
fan
if with so many shows you're just in
[ __ ] limbo you're like
you know just tell me if i'm gonna get
another season or tell me if i'm not i
just want to know should i just
go ahead and binge the manga
you should to be fair netflix has been
pretty good with br
like making season twos for that yeah
yeah we've gotten a lot better recently
but
yeah like i i was really enjoying myself
with daughter her daughter but
it just i just it just ended and i was
just feeling
like
it's been like since we [ __ ] started
the podcast when i watched this yeah
yeah but i remember that's two months
that's that's not two months
no it came out way earlier like four
months ago i watched that [ __ ]
really yeah yeah we haven't even we
haven't we didn't start this podcast
like four months ago
it's like 20 weeks ago yeah no it's
[ __ ] weird
this is episode 18 gone yeah so
i i i watched what the [ __ ] is 20 20 man
i was like this is episode five right
this is this is two this is
we've been on trash days for like two
months you're like a [ __ ] comatose
patient on the podcast bro
oh my god i watched it like then and i
remember being
really [ __ ] happy that it felt so
[ __ ] refreshing watching yeah
it was like a [ __ ] glass of orange
juice in the morning i was like damn
that's nice
yeah that's just the manga especially i
read a book
i read a few of the chapters of the
manga where it left off and i was i was
like holy [ __ ]
i should accuse art is just [ __ ]
insane i i felt
fine being like you know what i can tell
the story isn't getting to the best bits
and that's totally fine like i get it
no we're near getting to the best bits
that's fine is that not fine god i mean
it's fine it's just
is it fine it's just annoying right
because because
i because i like experiencing the best
part of stories i like seeing stories go
from like
at least hit one kind of climax because
i feel like there was like attack on
titan season two that's what it was
like my problem my problem with dora
hedorah was that i can't point to a
single
ass single part to be like this is a
huge climax happening right now it
doesn't have to have that though
that's literally the slice of life
[ __ ] like you literally just named
slice of life like
i feel like
in that sense is because it poses this
incredible world and these incredible
characters
and yet they really take their time to
like kind of
reality and they don't mind you showing
you the characters you might not be
interested in yeah like
because eventually they will become
interesting
building up this world okay like i
didn't give a [ __ ] about no i i i can
say this perfectly it just didn't it
didn't feel like a season
yeah it felt like it felt like all right
we've just run out run time let's just
let's just
cut the season off basically right like
with most anime seasons you have
you have some kind of climax you have a
season finale
this didn't this didn't really feel like
you had a season finale it just kind of
just
ended i don't know sometimes i feel like
i don't need that like sometimes the
ride is better than the the destination
you know what i mean
like i want a complete package with
myself well because i feel that i feel
the same thing kind of happened with b
stars as well the way like yeah
it wasn't it wasn't really i know that
that had a climax man
where was the climax the the stage
performance yeah no not just the sage
performance but they [ __ ]
when he i can't say this while going to
spoilers not spoilers just say spoilers
but when he saved haru well that was
pretty climactic that was
that was the end of a story i don't know
i don't know her daughter had
equivalents of that
when he let out his magic juice and they
had to
get it back or something how come what
happened something like that yeah i
remember just it being like [ __ ] hype
though i don't know like i
not everything like needs to have a neat
package gone yes it does no it does yes
it does no it doesn't yes
literally the lord each lord of the
rings movie like it's a mess
bro yeah because i think at least at the
end of the lord of the lord of the rings
movie
you know you still have some kind of
closure but it's like oh that was a cool
story
i swear like what the [ __ ] happens in
the second lord of the rings film at the
end
i don't remember there's two towers
that's the only thing i remember
that was that climactic battle at the
end of tuesday but that wasn't the end
of it though
like it wasn't the end of it that was
the end of the battle yeah the end of
the battle not the end of the movie
imagine if they just stopped mid-battle
no no you're just like
donna did not do that
we didn't we didn't get like a tokyo
season one because we didn't even get
that big climaxing battle winning
donaheddo
like but what what you okay megalobox
right was basically that
right we got no no no no it's a very
nice
you know it was a cool story had a very
nice package and that was [ __ ]
right it's not always what the [ __ ]
megalobox is great what are you talking
it was
boring bro box was like let's take ping
pong
and put it in a pa in like a boxing
setting
what did you like about mega box no no
no i love mega bloks in the first
viewing
i just said mega man i love mega bloks
i enjoyed it but at the same time i'm
like the story was just kind of like all
right
cool i mean i knew what was gonna happen
it was so [ __ ] obvious
like it was just kind of like all right
yeah i mean i'm not not to say that
megalo box is like the
was the greatest anime to come out of
that year but people were like it's the
[ __ ] great like people
are genuinely upset that it wasn't anime
of the the year right
i mean it wasn't that good it was i
would say i felt more complete i
mean i definitely felt more completely
watching megalo boxing yeah it was but
but i think door-to-door was better than
that megalo box for me i mean
for me like at the moment yeah you know
i can see that dodo herodoro
definitely had more potential to be good
than megalo box i'm just saying that
it didn't get near that point it didn't
[ __ ] get near that point and
i wanted something i want i wanted a
moment i could think back
to dorotheador and be like that was a
great show but to me i like baseball
[Music]
by the way if you're wondering why i'm
not as heavily involved it's because
i've read all the manga and i'm
completely satisfied with it so
yeah i'm sure the manga is amazing oh
yeah i didn't even watch the anime
because joey's that guy yeah i'm just
that guy i'm like
[ __ ] smug peasants mm-hmm yeah i'm
like
i'm like you peasants when [ __ ]
firewalls
is on the cross joey's like god you
should see what happens
you guys won't believe what he's about
to call him
i'm the guy in the cinema who like
mouths the what they say is
happening right like just wait till we
get to the cave yeah
you better keep your eye on the cave
yeah you guys thought that was
insignificant bro
yeah he's gonna come back
he's not gonna revive him he's literally
that guy
oh you like that character oh okay okay
all right
yeah have fun while it lasts have fun
with that yeah like oh you might not
want to get into it yeah
just just like forget what i'm saying it
means nothing but just like just don't
get invisible
when you have that friend who wants to
know that like is there anything gonna
happen to them i'm like don't ask me
that
don't ask me that oh no i'm absolutely
that guy that's like oh you'll see
you'll see